joe biden off his bike couldn't fall
dude can't ride a bike that good get him
off the bike
get that man
off of the bike
y'all know he's a senior citizen man
and that's as much citizen as you can
get that's it
okay that dude is right you know
that dude's hanging out right there on
uh
on the lord's doorstep dude
if the lord had a ring cam you would see
uh joe biden's on that thing
so don't tell me he ain't just he ain't
he ain't uh about dead
okay and y'all putting him on a bike
and you should be ashamed of yourself
his wife too
whatever her name is ronald ron
i don't know i don't know what her name
is
but you don't put that you don't put
that man on a damn bike
you don't put a senior citizen like that
on a bike and if you do put them in that
little seat in the back
and let somebody tough out there driving
around
but damn bro they put the man out there
just [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy bro dude trying
to do stunts and whatever he's doing
it's just
i don't like the way they parade in this
that man around he's just something's
you know he's not well
he's mentally getting older
and he just you can't do it it's not
fair i'm sure other countries look at
him
and they're like damn bro
so i just it's just time to stop you
know
to me it seems sad that we keep putting
him out because he don't seem well
and i think he's brave because he keeps
going out there but damn
get that man off at a damn bike
jeepers
what if somebody walked up and put your
granddaddy on a bike right now
what would you tell him
get him off the bike that's what you'd
tell him
but yeah he fell off his bike
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one